the following message is being
transmitted at the request of the
universal stability agency
a destabilizing paradoxical event is
currently taking place in the following
universes
u0001 u0002
u0003 u0004
u0005000
following educational broadcast is
brought to you by the universal
stability agency and made possible by
viewers like you please consider making
a donation to help keep the universe a
brighter place thank you for trusting
the usa and have a wonderful day
[Music]
why hello there
oh you seem to be having a good day
that's so wonderful
by the way look out
whoa
you gotta be careful you almost fell in
you do know what that is don't you
[Laughter]
why that's a wormhole silly don't tell
me you've never seen a wormhole before
well that's a surprise say
why don't you
just jump into that wormhole huh
are you sure oh come on it could be fun
you could cannonball right in there
maybe even do a flip
that is the right answer you just
perfectly demonstrated pedal to the
whole universe right now
yes pedal
peep eep don't lean
it's just that easy if you ever come
across a wormhole make the right choice
and back pedal away you made the right
choice to not jump in but remember in
the infinite multiverse there just might
be another version of you that may be
tempted to make a different choice
speaking of which i think there's
another you right over there
uh oh
looks like you're really thinking about
this one
[Music]
oh
no
looks like your other self is
experiencing a destabilizing paradoxical
event if only they would have remembered
pedal then your other self might have
avoided an eternity in spiraling chaos
doomed to choices already made and
perpetually obligated to choices never
even known
and for everyone at home
just remember you peep the wormhole you
eep away from the wormhole and you don't
under any circumstance leap into that
wormhole or else you just might bring
about the destruction of everything we
know
[Music]